[Music]
hello and welcome to indie world i'm a
rico and i'm tyler we're here to take
you through another great selection of
indie games coming to the nintendo
switch system no matter what type of
games you're into we hope you'll find
your next cindy favorite are you ready
then off we go
[Music]
do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
now this is what i call a funky future
i could use a backpack like that me too
starting out as a nobody in a sprawling
metropolis making a name for yourself
won't be easy
but as you expand your crew with
additional playable characters and make
use of the intuitive trick system to get
around town you'll edge closer to
becoming an all-city king
[Music]
by beats from a wide range of musical
talent you'll grind paint and combo your
way to becoming one of the greatest
graffiti artists around but you'd better
protect your neck because all that
artwork will attract some unwanted
attention
reclaim the streets when bomb rush cyber
funk arrives as a timed console
exclusive on nintendo switch next year
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
[Music]
hey hey son yoni class well yeah i liked
us we poured something made or
restaurant utrechtling's teammate eric
stolter for
[Music]
hey that's a nice one
it reminds me of the photos you can take
in this laid-back adventure that's all
about capturing the moment and helping
people out along the way with its
charming hand-drawn style you'll explore
different regions inspired by the
scandinavian countryside
chat with quirky characters solve their
problems by taking neat snaps with your
camera
and make your way through a relaxing
landscape while listening to some
totally chill beats
[Music]
get ready to say cheese
when toem arrives this fall
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey ariko does it feel like we're going
in circles here
don't worry tyler that's just how
loophero works
instead of playing as the hero you craft
adventures for them by creating the
world that they travel through
each mystical card you play forms part
of a dangerous path that the hero can
explore loot and fight along
place cards strategically to help them
conquer the loop and then do it all
again the more loops you complete the
more cards you'll uncover opening up new
possibilities for the hero's future
adventures between expanding the
survivor's campsite and fending off
devious guardians keeping them alive
takes strategy balance and skill
especially if you want to defeat the
time bending lich
break the spiral and save the world when
loop hero arrives on nintendo switch
this holiday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
co-founder and creative lead voc
[Music]
a boy his ship and an ocean that
stretches as far as the eye can see
who'd have thought that the apocalypse
would ever be so relaxing and yet it is
in this stirring puzzle-solving
adventure you get to captain your own
seafaring vessel and explore a vast
flooded landscape
tackle mighty storms and overcome
conundrums as you embark on a voyage to
find a new home
set in a beautifully realized
post-apocalyptic world it's an emotional
meditative journey that anyone can enjoy
whether you played the first game in the
series far loan sales or not set sail
for the horizon in far changing tides
coming to the nintendo switch system
next year
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that smells both rich and satisfying
i bet it's got enough caffeine to wake
the dead
can i get a cup sure flavorsome
storytelling and aromatic atmosphere go
hand in hand in this anime-style
experience where the dead get one last
night to mingle with the living and
discuss the finer points of life and
death over a beverage or two immerse
yourself in new story content and enjoy
remastered visuals in this expanded
director's cut of the original game
there's even a new studio mode where you
can create your own dialogue and stories
make yours a grande with necrobarista
final pour launching is a timed console
exclusive on nintendo switch later today
[Music]
it's time for some updates
let's quickly catch up on several games
we featured previously in indie world
that you can play today
it's time to grow your own adventure
become the guardian of the grove and
explore a vibrant island to inspire its
inhabitants
bend off the invasive rot and rebuild
your home
take on requests from villagers
solve puzzles and do everything you can
to help restore the community rise to
grapeness and garden story arriving as a
timed console exclusive on nintendo
switch later today
don't just fight with a sword
date one
in this heartfelt dungeon crawling
dating sim use the in-game cash you
earned from fighting monsters to woo
your weapons on romantic outings
multiple combat styles just means more
cuties to forge relationships with after
all a couple that slays together stays
together
capture the hearts of your arsenal and
boyfriend dungeon cleaving its way onto
nintendo switch later today
in this prequel to the original axiom
verge a new hero fights for her life
empowered by the same microscopic
machines that gradually consume her
humanity
with two interconnected worlds to
explore
hack and fight your way through
walk that thin line between dream and
nightmare as you discover the origins of
the axiom verge universe
axiom verge 2 comes to nintendo switch
later today
[Music]
i can't wait to dig into all those games
speaking of digging let's continue with
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
i'm celia from yacht club games we are
thrilled to announce today that shovel
knight pocket dungeon an action-packed
puzzle adventure with a dungeon-crawling
twist we're developing alongside vine is
coming to nintendo switch can you
believe it's been seven years since
shovel knight first arrived on the scene
after that first appearance we've been
hard at work releasing plague of shadows
spectre of torment king of cards and
shovel knight showdown
as you can see we've always envisioned
shovel knight as a grand
all-encompassing franchise which is why
we're so excited for shovel knight to
take the next step into a new gameplay
dimension with pocket dungeon
we hope you enjoy your puzzling
adventure
[Music]
now here's a twist on shovel knight that
you're really going to dig
a part puzzler part dungeon crawler
hybrid that's perfect for fans and
newcomers alike
with puzzle night by your side fight
bows recover relics and battle bosses
both new and familiar
group together enemies to unleash
massive chain attacks and grab keys
potions and treasure as you try to
escape the mysterious pocket dungeon
with over 10 heroes available each with
their own special power and play style
the action is always as fresh as it is
fast
you can even take on a friend head to
head and fight to bury the competition
literally
and as an exclusive feature to nintendo
switch if you have any of the shovel
knight series amiibo figures use them to
call on a familiar fairy friend to
accompany you on your adventure it'll be
a night to remember when shovel knight
pocket dungeon is unearthed on nintendo
switch this holiday
[Music]
[Music]
start small build big that's always been
my motto
and in this quirky city builder it can
be yours too this procedurally generated
strategy game sees you placing buildings
from your inventory on an island to earn
points score enough and you'll get more
buildings to keep growing your island
with
and when you can't build any further
just start from scratch and do it all
again
with its minimalist approach intuitive
mechanics and almost infinite colorful
islands to build on you can create the
city of your dreams over and over in no
time at all the world is yours to build
in islanders console edition coming as a
timed console exclusive on nintendo
switch later today
marco
theo
therma
[Music]
so
[Music]
free
here's a fresh take on metal slug that
moves the classic action franchise into
a new dimension this new game retains
all the things fans are familiar with
from the original series like the
detailed pixel art and explosive action
but then adds tactical combat mechanics
to mix things up taking control of
familiar heroes from the metal select
series including marco tarma theo and
arie it's your job to wipe out the enemy
forces by any means possible position
your troops correctly on the battlefield
and you'll even be able to use the sync
skill to deal extra damage with multiple
heroes head for a new front line when
metal slug tactics blast onto nintendo
switch next year
and i'm eileen i work on pr and
production at enhance and today we're so
excited to announce that tetris effect
connected is coming to nintendo's switch
no games
without
check it out
sure you might have already played
tetris but tetris effect connected is
something different it's the iconic
puzzle game but one that goes to another
plane of enlightenment as well as the
single-player journey mode
take on your friends competitively in
zone battle locally or online or play
connected mode and work together to
clear three playfields as one
it even includes cross-platform
multiplayer so it's easier to find
people to play with or against
and since it's on the nintendo switch
system you can take the experience with
you wherever you are feel the connection
in tetris effect connected
arriving on nintendo switch
october 8th
there sure are a lot of games to look
forward to but that's not all there are
even more indie titles coming to
nintendo switch soon
take a look
[Music]
exceptional
[Music]
[Music]
we're nearly done but before we go
here's an update on another game coming
to nintendo switch very soon from our
friends at chucklefish
[Music]
[Applause]
it's nearly time to head eastward coming
to nintendo switch as a timed console
exclusive september 16th
pre-orders begin on nintendo eshop
later today
so that's the end of today's indie world
there are so many diverse indie games to
be found on nintendo switch and we
really enjoy showing them to you on
behalf of our many development and
publishing partners around the world as
always a big thank you to everyone in
the indie community working on games for
nintendo switch and thank you for
joining us today don't forget to follow
our official twitter account
at indieworld n a to stay up to date on
all the latest news from indie world
until next time happy gaming
[Music]
you